j'ai 30 ans dix neuf ans ça reste jeunes
après y'a pas d'âge je peux avoir 20 ans
je peux avoir une sacrée gamberge troupe
est mature je perd son papa je veux
vraiment ma femme je sens que lula sera
avec ma femme dans son comportement
comment elle me parle comme à ce projet
être aussi avec moi avec ma fille
mais là les jeunes parce qu'elle va pas
se dire en fait c'est compliqué pour moi
le rôle de belle-mère
en fait j'ai très peur qu'elle met vendu
du rêve bien sûr l'écran dès qu en face
de moi fait ça sera un match où anthony
tu attends et luna avait 19 ans c'est ça
mais franchement c'est pascal à la luna
luna ce qu'on peut voir une photo me
noda qui était très sympathique très
joli
nous discutions ensemble depuis combien
de temps depuis six mois donc elle a
envoyé le premier ça le premier message
sur les réseaux sociaux ouais donc après
on a de continuer à discuter pendant six
mois jusqu'au jour après belle
opportunité nous voilà avec m6 de se
rencontrer dans un endroit magnifique
bien sûr alors c'était notre première
rencontre la première vous et istres
essayer de savoir s'ils allaient pouvoir
remplir un rôle de belle-mère parce que
vous avez vous avez déjà un roulage papa
d'une petite fille de quatre ans
exactement on va voir elle n'a que 19
ans luna mais et nous laisser son âge le
sort ne soit pas
changé seulement on a bien échangé son
est plutôt courant et bah c'est parti
zizou voir mes copines à me hisser par
dû profiter de ma jeunesse mais tout en
me canalise en posant quand je lui ai
expliqué moi je donne fille je veux pas
deux enfants la maison des contes et une
vie de famille sajama ceux du dedans
c'était peut-être bah ouais je suis
prête à m'occuper de sa fille à vivre
avec eux tous les matins avec paf
laisser songeur
à plus de 16 15 heures ces maudits après
l'autre je veux pas c'est officiel sera
perdue battoir aussi un rôle de
belle-mère la vie de famille quant aux
fins l'est virtuellement je le prenais
un peu comme un monde irréel maintenant
de parler
en face à face on dans la réalité je
prends une claque qu'elle cesse
ses nymphes oméga c'est le même tapis
tu vas pouvoir le voir souvent chez toi
aussi tu vas rester beaucoup à la maison
tu vas si je vais pouvoir bien nettoyer
anthony donc luna donc vous aviez un
vrai creux champ mais bien sûr
physiquement c'était une très belle
femme bien sûr mois par seulement quand
je me suis séparé donc de trois mois
après quand je les rencontre et sur les
réseaux et donc on parlait pratiquement
tous les jours voilà quand on t'a 30
antennes jeunes filles comme ça qui
vient tout d'abord débat je vais être
franc ils étaient super contents voilà
on se parlait bien malgré qu'elle ait
des voix laquelle et des bagues ça m'a
pas arrêté
parce que c'est ce que nous dit les gens
sont
donc non non c'était par rapport à son
âge elle est toute jeune à l'encore des
bagues et les
gâteaux moi je sais que voilà l'ex de
daniel avait des blagueurs fou il y
avait non mais sans déconner ça c'est
parce que en fait ils parlaient de mac
parce que juste sur les réseaux gens
l'appellent banque mondiale et l hyper
jeunes à la débâcle bien sûr ça n'a rien
à voir exactement à des adolescentes
mais c'est vrai qu'elle est magnifique
mais elle a décidé
dans bat eric anthony ou de repartir
seul regardez la décision de luna
comme je te laisse je suis encore jeune
je découvre la vie je veux juste y aller
a mûri au coeur je préférerais partir
seul ce soir
choquée je suis triste je me sens un peu
con un peu trahi je comprends pas du
tout son choix je ne dise pas possible
réfléchis bien d'accord je te force soit
rien du tout
mais ce soir je prépare ou partir c'est
finalement dans un monde irréel virtuel
je vois
faire la femme
peut plus sortir pendant mes copines
faire passer ma vie de famille avant et
quand on lui face à la réalité j'ai pas
envie d'abandonner mon petit train de
vivre je me rends compte que la vie
quand on lui propose et une vie que
j'aimerais vivre mi-temps 5 6 ans sur
tout le réseau alors non ne faut pas
quand on peut alors vous imaginez vous
êtes dans la voiture vous prenez en
avant par exemple aiderait capoter
derrière non mais non mais non en tout
étaient tristes ou pas dans son cheptel
triste parce que toi qu'est
l'adolescence où il n'avait l'air
sincère en plus j'aime bien bien sûr par
ailleurs après voilà comme j'ai dis moi
j'ai jamais vu de famille j'ai mes
projets tout sa nature j'étais la raie
manta chez un médecin après ça s'est
fini dans le sens où elle voulait pas
aller plus loin faux sur une famille
ensemble assez sur moi c'était le but
aussi c'est quand je lui posais la clé
c'est pas la clé pour rester à l'hôtel
qu'on est ensemble et voilà la clé du
bonheur continue voilà à les jeunes
c'est la ligne jaune sorti accélère se
découvre il attend toi tu oublies le
proposait la clé de ton coeur c'est ça
fonctionne mieux qu'on continue à se
parler mais
anthony les sincères annoncé mais j'aime
bien c'est rare et je trouve anthony
franchement moi je lis j'ai joué j'ai eu
un petit croche pour toi enfin voila je
ne mange pas sûr que même pas des
krisprolls en rien du tout mais c'est
vrai que ballack c'est bien parce que je
trouve qu'il était sincère et que tu
étais au voile aptitudes j'ai bien aimé
ta sincérité et de galeries qui adore
cette émission moi je trouve que
justement tu as peut-être été un peu
angoissant avec la petite moi c'est ça
ouais ce qu'elle trouvait trop sérieux
et a trouvé trois dans l'engagement et
règlements alors on sait que souvent
c'est les hommes qui fuit l'engagement
mais là je pense que tu as été un peu
fort engagement je connais depuis six
mois et tu juppé est ressentie je pense
un petit peu oppressés par la situation
et elle a été hyper on est
hyper honnête dit sincèrement qu'en gros
bas elle s'y voyait à distance mais face
à toi même si je vois plus quoi faire
a été battu le coach l'a dit ce moment
je parle d'enfants et de familles c'est
sûr ça peut faire peur bonjour voila
une autre épisode rires on n'était pas
juste après je vous laisse moi même je
vais 3 je voulais le dire comment
comment j'étais après voilà dans la main
je ressens maintenant énormément de mal
à st de appelé la police sur les sur les
réseaux anthony leur a pris plein la
gueule parce qu'ils ont trouvé vraiment
luna très très jeune par rapport à lui
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
avez trouvé ça choquant pas du tout que
j'ai à moi pas du tout je vous ai trouvé
exceptionnel est elle aussi en fait vous
ai trouvé tous les deux très juste et
très naturelle parce qu'en fait c'est
quand même elle qui acceptent cette
relation virtuelle pendant six mois donc
elle parlait elle connaît votre âge vous
connaissez le sien elle et elle est
consentante allait pas sous emprise et à
partir du moment où vous voyez comme
astro que c'est normal vous prenez un
râteau sait jamais très agréable mais il
a plein de gens qui ont dit un petit peu
comme kelly qui ont dit voilà anthony
tut tut tut chez bon une meuf de 19 ans
mais non mais non mais tu che - un homme
de 19 ans et tu étais un peu trop mon
truc tu cherchais une belle mère une
belle-mère exercice a devancé colas je
comprends moi je comprends lunar aussi à
huy droite à 29 ans il est peut-être
aussi qu'on se retrouver mais je ne les
blâme en mai mais vous imaginez quand il
rencontre laetitia les jeunes mais pour
ça il fonde une femme tu vois la
personne mais aussi bien sûr faire
la part des choses ouaip était lourd
benjamin je comprends que ça choque
louis g lorsqu'on prépare un petit peu
plus fort où je comprends que sacha dans
une vidéothèque le sait peut-être je
pense que vieux jeu mais c'est vrai que
29 39 mois pourquoi pas 19 ans 30 ans et
19 ans en fait voilà c'est ça c'est une
jeune femme elle a toute la vie devant
elle et c'est vrai que d'avoir quelqu'un
qui me dit voilà je te veux comme bel
max je comprends que c'est un xv ça
dérange est vrai que 19 ans et 1 c'est
une très jeune femme alors légalement ya
pas de problème mais moralement je sais
pas si je serai pas taxés que les jeter
un peu vieux jeu rapprocher les gens à
en tout je te le dis je le disais si si
tu cherches est vraiment une fille de ta
famille kita c'est vrai que cherchait
une jeune fille de 19 ans s'est
peut-être pas là des canadiens possible
c'est pas le bon angle à tingwick au
soleil a rien de choquant on sait juste
que l'émission en fait ils ont oublié de
trouver des angles à chaque fois et que
là ils n'ont pas arrêté de répéter
qu'elle avait que 19 ans et que nous a
dit ça a été remonté sur mon pays trafic
les sonore et c'est pour ça qu'il a reçu
des messages mais a déjà eu d'autres
candidats qui avait de telles
différences d'âge et personne ne disait
rien sachez que les personnes et en plus
vous dire anthony c'est un des rares
candidats sincère de l'émission jean
reproche aux candidats d'être fake des
comédiens et vous on sent que vous étiez
saint céré dommage et surtout j'ai
jamais caché que j'avais une petite
chute l'agent peut dire beaucoup tu vas
avoir peur je vais chez ça on sait
jamais les jeunes jettent est affiliée à
laquelle à 19 en quatre ans
longtemps il a eu en 11 ans at-il
connard
anthony et spectacles qu'un maintenant
non toujours célibataire c'est vrai tu
chercheras des battles cherche l'amour
je laisse ça viendra aujourd'hui je
l'espère ça fait quarante cinq ans
qu'elle dit c'est pas les caméras aussi
vous avez voulu vous donner un autre
personnage
venu accompagné soit oui ah bon haas
company 2 qui bien sûr d'une collègue
d'une amie
me connaît tourné au
sonhir la
colonie attention le moment pas là il
est partout anaïs et tout hanouna les
saints row débusquer alors bon soir la
dame va arriver va alors oui en effet je
vois tu dois texas rangers
la journée
sera longue vie tantôt nous
[Rires]
c'est très bien merci vous a été aussi
et c'est on se rencontrait et oui alors
vous attendez tous le néant
c'était une très belle expérience mais
malheureusement pourquoi vous mettez pas
ensemble
j'ai 17 ans donc c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais paris et oui parce que c'est un ami
c'est un ami seriez vous êtes en
prennent john est un mythe la personne
que j'étais venu rencontrer non ah ouais
pourquoi les amis de des amis de hamid
compliqué après non mais c'est vrai mais
en tout cas cendres donc là d'un maçon
présenteront c'était ça vous êtes devenu
super pote ça comme ça ouais c'est bien
ça va super merci
amis mais rien n'y a rien
on va
vous aider vous deux vous cherchez une
relation sérieuse alors je veux dire et
je connais très bien loin je n'ai pas
envie d'être belle maman
allez c'est bon écoutez ça m'a fait
plaisir merci beaucoup merci tu reviens
quand tu veux voilà en tout
il a ainsi tu as besoin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est réglé sa
place à l'amour l'amour
bon tantôt merci d'avoir été là si celle
ci avoue si je pense à quelqu'un je dois
présenter j'ai fait un bail qu'on va
offrir anormale
qui a déjà une petite fille manon mais
j'essaie de quelqu'un pour te refais
amiraux couple je te cache pas que j'ai
peut-être quelqu'un pour toi je te
quelqu'un en tête sur tous les dossiers
un pas du tout j'ai la chance d'avoir
une agence matrimoniale j'ai peut-être
une copine à tony kelly je vais lui dire
qui c'est vrai elle va me dire peut-être
c'est pas mal c'est quelqu'un qu'on
connaît quelqu'un n'en retenait sans
faute et non
les questions lourd toit et michard des
vannes de divergent donc faire des
folies